escribe de nuevo la ecuación 6x cuadrada
3 es igual a 12 x menos 6 en su forma
estándar e identifica a b y c y bueno
esencialmente tener una ecuación
cuadrática de la forma estándar es tener
algo de la forma a x cuadrada más b x
más c esto igual a 20 perfecto y para
esto lo que tenemos que hacer es pasar
todo el lado izquierdo de la ecuación
para que esté igualada a cero y además
ordenar los términos de la siguiente
manera tener primero los términos que
tienen que ver con x cuadrada después
los términos que tienen que ver con la x
normal y después los términos que tienen
que ver con la constante así que para
esto déjame primero escribir otra vez de
nuevo esta ecuación me va a quedar 6x
cuadrada
+ 3 esto es igual a 2 x menos 6 así que
bueno para pasar a la forma estándar lo
que hay que hacer es pasar estos
términos que están del lado derecho al
lado izquierdo muy bien lo primero que
voy a hacer es quitar este 2x del lado
derecho de la ecuación y para esto lo
que voy a hacer es agregar menos 2x de
ambos lados de la ecuación y entonces
que me va a quedar 6x cuadrada y ojo voy
a poner primero 6x cuadrada para ir
acomodando estos términos de tal manera
que los tenga de forma decreciente es
decir primero los términos que tienen
que ver con x cuadrada después los
términos que tienen que ver con x y
después los términos que tienen que ver
con la constante 6x cuadrada menos 2 x +
esto es igual y bueno del lado derecho 2
x 2 x se cancelan y solamente me queda
menos 6 y bueno ahora también voy a
pasar el menos 6 del otro lado de la
ecuación y para esto lo que voy a hacer
es cambiar de color y sumar 6 de ambos
lados de la ecuación de este lado voy a
sumar 6 y de este lado también voy a
sumar 6 entonces que me va a quedar 6 x
cuadrada menos 2 x 3 + 6 me dan 9 y del
otro lado menos seis más 6 se cancelan y
simple sencillamente me quedan 0 llevar
la pregunta es ya estamos en la forma
estándar y date cuenta que si ya tenemos
esta igualdad a 0 y además tenemos los
términos acomodados de forma decreciente
según las potencias de x es decir
primero tenemos lo que tiene que ver con
x cuadrada después lo que tiene que ver
con la x la primera potencia y después
lo que tiene que ver con la constante y
entonces ya tenemos la forma x cuadrada
más bx más c igual a 0 perfecto porque
entonces ya estamos en forma estándar
entonces lo único que nos falta es
encontrar a b y c a en sus confesiones
instalados del x cuadrado
en este caso a vale 6 b es el
coeficiente que está al lado de la equis
pero aquí está la clave de en este caso
vale menos 2 aquí dice más bx pero como
el coeficiente que está al lado de la
equis es un número negativo hay que
tomar todo este coeficiente con todo el
signo entonces vamos a escribir que b
vale menos 2 y por último vamos a ver
cuánto vale el valor de sem que es el
valor constante que tenemos en la
ecuación que en este caso vale 9 por lo
tanto puedo decir que se vale 9